- Regierungen müssen
sich heute mit dem Wandel
auseinandersetzen, den die
Technologie mit sich bringt.
Die veränderten Erwartungen
und Anforderungen der
Bürger und der Servicestandards haben dazu
geführt, dass Regierungen
weltweit nach neuen
Definitionen für Design und
Bereitstellung suchen müssen.
GX Now verfolgt wichtige
Regierungen auf der ganzen
Welt, in der Hoffnung,
Antworten darauf zu finden,
wie die Regierungen von
morgen aussehen werden.
Wie sie Spitzenleistungen
erbringen und warum Erlebnisse
vielleicht der Schlüssel
sind, um den Wert hinter
dem Engagement der Bürger in
der Regierung zu erschließen.
GX ist eine Idee, die in den
Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten geboren wurde,
um das Versprechen der Erbringung
von Regierungsdienstleistungen zu erfüllen
und sie in ein Erlebnis zu verwandeln.
Das Modell entwickelt
sich nun langsam zu einer
Vorlage, die weltweit
eingesetzt werden kann,
um eine exzellente
Dienstleistungserbringung
in der Regierung zu schaffen.
In GX Now hören Sie eine Sammlung
von globalen Perspektiven,
die sowohl aus dem
öffentlichen als auch aus
dem privaten Sektor kommen.
Die Meinungen der Gäste in
diesem Dokumentarfilm basieren
zu einem großen Teil
auf ihren Erfahrungen in
der Zusammenarbeit mit Regierungen
und in Schlüsselpositionen,
in denen Regierungen
und der private Sektor aufeinandertreffen.
Ein Blick auf einige der
größten Chancen, die vor
uns liegen, und auch auf einige
der Herausforderungen, denen
sich Regierungen in den
nächsten Jahren stellen müssen.
GX Now ist die Geschichte
des großen Traums
von Exzellenz, der
Veränderung von Wahrnehmungen
und der Schaffung einer besseren Zukunft
für Regierungsdienstleistungen weltweit.
Mein Name ist Ian Khan.
Danke, dass Sie mich auf
dieser Reise begleiten.
Wenn Sie sich den aktuellen
Stand des Erfahrungsbereichs der
Regierung ansehen, gibt es
nicht wirklich einen Standard.
Jeder auf der Welt macht die Dinge
anders, und es gibt einen Einfluss der
verschiedenen Branchen auf
die Erfahrungen der Regierung.
Und in einigen Teilen der Welt wird die
Regierung durch den Einzelhandel
diktiert, und wir stellen
einen Vergleich zwischen
Einzelhandelsdienstleistungen
und Regierungsdienstleistungen an.
Was innerhalb der Regierung geschieht, ist
auch eine Nachwirkung dessen, wie andere
Branchen ihre Kunden und
ihren Kundenstamm bedienen.
Die Regierungen auf der ganzen Welt
versuchen, sich an
verschiedene Dinge anzupassen.
Und in Zeiten politischer
Instabilität, wechselnder
Regierungen, ändern sich die
Prioritäten der Regierungen.
Lassen Sie uns mit Jonathan
Reichental sprechen.
Ich sprach mit Jonathan über
seine Erfahrungen und die, die
er bei Regierungen auf der
ganzen Welt gesehen hat.
Jetzt arbeitet Jonathan mit
Regierungen von Asien über den
Mittleren Osten bis nach
Amerika und auch in Europa.
Und er kennt den Puls der Regierungen und
die Herausforderungen, vor
denen die Regierungen stehen.
Jonathan ist ein großer
Verfechter des Wandels
als Professor, als Pädagoge
und als Geschäftsinhaber.
Seine Gedanken sind
entscheidend, um zu verstehen,
wohin wir gehen sollten
und was Regierungen
tun sollten, um Fortschritte zu erzielen.
- Eines der Dinge, die
ich beobachte, während ich
das Privileg habe, viele
verschiedene Regierungen und Städte
auf der ganzen Welt zu besuchen, ist die
Erkenntnis, dass die Gemeinden
heute viel höhere Erwartungen
an die Erbringung von
Dienstleistungen haben.
Wenn Sie also ein Mitglied der
Community sind, sind Sie es
gewohnt, Verbraucher-Apps auf
Ihrem Smartphone zu nutzen
oder auf eine Website zu
gehen, und dann nutzen
Sie einen Regierungsdienst
und der ist nicht annähernd so
gut oder vielleicht ist
er nicht einmal digital.
Wir spüren, dass dies nicht mehr länger
akzeptabel ist und müssen
das Spiel beschleunigen.
- Eine Teilnehmerin des
GX-Programms ist Jane Wiseman.
Ich habe mit Jane darüber gesprochen,
was die Herausforderungen
der Regierung sind und womit Regierungen
und die Veteranengemeinde
konfrontiert sind,
besonders in den Vereinigten Staaten,
und was ihre Erfahrungen
mit dem Regierungsdienst
und dessen Qualität sind.
- Die Hälfte der Amerikaner
kann den Unterschied zwischen
einem Google-Suchergebnis
und einer Google-Anzeige nicht erkennen.
Wir brauchen eine bessere
Datenkompetenz, damit wir
wissen, was zuverlässige
Quellen für Fakten sind.
- Tim Unwin hat den UNESCO-Lehrstuhl für
ICT inne und ist außerdem Professor
an der Royal Holloway
University in London.
Tim bringt eine Menge
Erfahrung mit, wenn es
darum geht, international
an der Basis zu arbeiten.
Und wie steht es um die Erfahrungen
und Dienstleistungen
der Regierung in Europa.
- In vielen Ländern der Welt haben die
Menschen kein Vertrauen
in ihre Regierungen.
Und ich spreche aus meiner
Erfahrung in Afrika.
Sie sind oft bereit, dem privaten
Sektor eher zu vertrauen als Regierungen.
Ich denke also, es gibt
einige wirklich interessante
Dinge in diesem Bereich,
aber wenn die Menschen
den Regierungen nicht vertrauen,
werden sie nicht bereit
sein, sich auf diese
Dienstleistungen einzulassen.
Es sei denn natürlich, die Regierung macht
dies über ihre digitalen
Systeme zwingend erforderlich.
Ich erinnere mich, dass
vor ein paar Jahren
viele Länder sagten, wir
werden standardmäßig digital,
aber das schließt
automatisch diejenigen aus,
die nicht digital sind.
Menschen mit Behinderungen,
ältere Menschen - sie werden
durch jede Umstellung auf
staatliche Dienstleistungen
an den Rand gedrängt,
es sei denn, es werden alternative
Mechanismen eingeführt.
Sie müssen also tatsächlich
Service-Zentren bereitstellen,
zu denen die Leute kommen können.
Also wird digital standardmäßig
an den Rand gedrängt.
- Marloes Pomp war der
Leiter der Blockchain
und der Leiter der
KI-Partnerschaften für die
Regierung der Niederlande ist
eine erstaunliche Ressource.
Sie hat so viel Wissen und
Informationen, weil sie mit
anderen Regierungen aus der
ganzen Welt zusammenarbeitet.
Als Leiter von Blockchain und einigen sehr
kritischen Programmen der
Regierung der Niederlande.
Marloes weiß, vor welchen
Herausforderungen Regierungen
stehen, wenn es um die
Implementierung von Technologien
- geht. In den Niederlanden
hat die Regierung fünf
Schlüsseltechnologien wie Blockchain, KI,
Big Data, Cybersicherheit
und 5g ausgewählt.
Und wir werden in den
kommenden Jahren weiter in
diese Technologie investieren,
um die Dienste zu verbessern.
Wir versuchen, eine
menschenzentrierte Anwendung zu bauen.
Das bedeutet auch, dass wir
viele Leute haben, die sich mit
den Risiken dieser neuen
Technologien auseinandersetzen,
z.B. nutzt die Regierung
bereits eine Menge KI
in ihren Diensten,
aber natürlich gibt es auch
das Risiko der Diskriminierung.
Aus diesem Grund hat das
Justizministerium eine
Richtlinie für alle staatlichen
Dienste eingeführt, die
neue Technologien wie
künstliche Intelligenz nutzen.
- Ich habe auch mit dem Leiter
der e-Residency der estnischen
Regierung gesprochen.
Ott Vatter arbeitet seit
vielen Jahren für die
Regierung Estlands, und er
bringt eine Menge Erfahrung
mit, wenn es um die Arbeit
mit Startups, die Arbeit mit
internationalen Gremien,
internationalen Regierungen geht,
und er teilte einige wirklich
kritische Einblicke, wenn
es um Erfahrungen mit der Regierung geht.
Und was hat es mit dem
e-Residency-Programm auf sich,
und warum ist es so ein
großartiges Beispiel für die
Schaffung einer nahtlosen
Regierungserfahrung, die für jedes
Land, egal welcher Größe, einen
enormen Mehrwert darstellt.
- Der Unterschied zwischen den
Regierungsdiensten in der EU,
in Asien und in den USA ist sehr groß und
die EU hat hier einige
Ähnlichkeiten, aber wenn man sich
konservative Länder anschaut,
die vielleicht nicht so
viel Vertrauen in die Regierung
haben oder in die Regierung,
die ihre Daten sicher aufbewahrt,
was auch sehr wichtig ist,
dann können sich diese
Dienste nicht entwickeln.
Wenn man sich Länder wie
Indien anschaut, die ebenfalls
ein Identitätsprogramm einführen,
aber 1,3 Milliarden im Vergleich
zu unseren 1,3 Millionen
in Estland ist schon eine
etwas andere Herausforderung.
- Estland ist eines der größten
Beispiele, das genutzt wird,
wenn es darum geht, dass die
Regierung Technologie einsetzt
und Effizienz in dem schafft,
was die Regierung tut.
Ich habe mit dem CIO der
Regierung von Estland
Siim Sikkut gesprochen.
Wir sprechen darüber,
welche Herausforderungen er
zu meistern hatte und wie er
die Regierungsarbeit aus
estnischer Sicht sieht.
- Unser Hauptansatz ist es, Dienste so
weit wie möglich unsichtbar zu machen.
Konzentrieren wir uns
nicht auf Interaktionen,
sondern darauf, einen Wert zu liefern.
Der Wert ist also zum Beispiel,
dass wir die Einhaltung der
Vorschriften sicherstellen,
daher bitten wir den Unternehmer
um eine Art Bericht, auch
wenn wir ihn online fragen.
Und ich will damit
sagen, dass wir, wenn wir
es aus dieser Perspektive
betrachten, oft sehen, dass wir
diese einzelnen Interaktionen
nicht als Dienste entwerfen müssen.
Wir können viele
Online-Dienste buchstäblich
loswerden, indem wir
Dinge wegautomatisieren.
Und wenn wir also die
Philosophie-Seite brauchen,
bedeutet das praktisch, dass
wir versuchen, verschiedene
Online-Dienste, die wir
aufgebaut haben, mindestens zu
töten, indem wir mehr
Automatisierung, mehr Art
von Datenintegration, ein
bisschen mehr kleine Datenanalyse
und so weiter hinzufügen.
Einer der ersten Ansätze ist,
dass Eltern von Neugeborenen kein
Elterngeld beantragen müssen, es wird
ihnen automatisch zugebilligt.
Wir bauen es für Unternehmen auf, dass,
wenn Unternehmen zustimmen
und zustimmen, die Regierung
Zugang zu den finanziellen
Aufzeichnungen hat, die
gleichen Daten, die
sowieso digital sind, dann
werden wir sie nie mit einem Bericht
belästigen, nicht für Steuern,
nicht für Beschäftigung,
nicht für Statistiken,
nicht für Jahresberichte und so weiter.
All diese Dinge können die
Unternehmen jetzt online
erledigen, warum stören wir
sie mit noch einem Schritt?
Wenn Sie die Daten haben, ist es
- geschafft. Es gibt
definitiv Ausreißer und es
gibt definitiv Länder, die
eine solide Anstrengung
in die richtige Richtung machen.
Das Engagement der Regierung der VAE
für die Initiative "Government
Experience" vollständig
zu verstehen und einen
Präzedenzfall in der
Erbringung von
Regierungsdienstleistungen zu schaffen.
Ich habe mit jemandem gesprochen, der
diese Bemühungen im Büro
des Premierministers
in den VAE leitet, Mohamed Bin Taliah.
- In der Vergangenheit lag der Fokus mehr
darauf, wie wir die Dienste in Bezug
auf Prozesse aufbauen, in
Bezug auf die Umwandlung
von manuellen Diensten in
automatische und papierlose.
Allerdings suchen die Kunden
heute nach Diensten, die
sich mehr an ihren
Erfahrungen und anderen Teilen
der Welt orientieren, mit
denen sie vertraut sind.
Und sie würden gerne sehen,
dass staatliche Dienstleistungen
auf ähnliche oder sogar
bessere Weise erbracht werden.
- Alain Bejjani ist der CEO der Majid Al
Futtaim Group in den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten.
Die Majid Al Futtaim
Group ist eine der größten
Gruppen, die den Einzelhandel
im Nahen Osten leitet.
Alain teilte eine Menge
kritischer Einsichten,
wie der Einzelhandel die
Regierung beeinflusst,
wie Regierungen vom
Einzelhandel lernen können.
Alain arbeitet auch für das
Weltwirtschaftsforum und
verschiedene Regierungen und
Gremien, um Ideen und Initiativen
zu entwickeln, die Regierungen
weltweit betreffen.
- Die vierte industrielle Revolution
ist darin eine Realität.
Und ich würde sagen, es ist sehr wichtig,
dass die Veränderungsrate im
Inneren mindestens gleich, wenn
nicht schneller ist als die
Veränderungsrate im Äußeren.
Sie ermöglicht es uns auch, mit einigen
der endemischen Probleme
umzugehen, mit denen wir
früher nicht umgehen konnten.
Die heutige Technologie
bietet die Möglichkeit, dies zu tun
und wird immer allgegenwärtiger,
erschwinglicher und
einfacher in der Anwendung.
Es liegt nun an uns,
unserer Generation von
Führungskräften, dafür zu
sorgen, dass wir dies in
die Chance verwandeln, die
es tatsächlich ist, und dafür
zu sorgen, dass wir nachhaltiges
Wirtschaftswachstum,
die Schaffung von Arbeitsplätzen
und die bessere Integration
unserer Gesellschaften in
der Welt vorantreiben können.
- Fadi Hindi ist CEO eines auf
KI basierenden Unternehmens,
das sich auf die Versicherungsbranche
konzentriert, aber er
bringt viele kritische Einsichten
in die Idee von GX ein.
- In den letzten, vielleicht
fünf bis acht Jahren,
sind die Kunden nicht mehr bereit,
Verzögerungen oder mangelnde Transparenz
zu tolerieren oder nicht
zu wissen, was der nächste
Schritt ist, oder gar
schlecht behandelt zu werden.
Historisch gesehen war
die Wirtschaft in den
siebziger Jahren eher
produktorientiert, dann kamen die
achtziger und neunziger
Jahre, und jetzt bewegt
sie sich mehr in Richtung
einer Beziehungswirtschaft.
- Wir leben in der Erlebniswirtschaft, und
ich denke, das ist etwas, das
Sie immer mehr und mehr sehen werden.
Wenn Sie über die Anstrengungen
nachdenken, die wir alle
zusammen unternehmen, der private Sektor,
der öffentliche Sektor und
wie wir alle versuchen, alles
auf den Kunden auszurichten,
stellen Sie sicher,
dass der Kunde tatsächlich
im Mittelpunkt steht.
Und wie können wir tatsächlich,
vom Standpunkt der Regierung
aus, zu dieser Lebensqualität
beitragen, dazu beitragen,
dass sie all die Unsicherheiten,
die damit einhergehen,
wegnehmen und ihnen die
Möglichkeit geben, sich auf das zu
konzentrieren, worauf sie sich
konzentrieren möchten, was
sie am meisten lieben und
was ihnen am besten gefällt,
nämlich einen Service, der
erstens um sie herum kuratiert
ist, zweitens, dass er da
ist, wenn sie ihn brauchen.
Und denken Sie tatsächlich darüber nach,
was der Kunde Schrägstrich Bürger braucht
und nicht, was die Regierung braucht.
Sehr lange Zeit haben sich die Regierungen
darauf konzentriert, Dienste
tatsächlich zu entwerfen oder
diese Entwürfe so zu
implementieren, dass sie
den Regierungen aus verschiedenen
Perspektiven passen.
Und ich denke, was Sie hier
sehen, ist eigentlich
ein totaler Unterschied.
- Ich habe mit der
Regierung in Aserbaidschan
und dem Leiter des
ASAN-Servicecenters gesprochen.
Die ASAN-Servicezentren haben die Idee der
Servicebereitstellung
komplett verändert, indem sie
verschiedene Anbieter und
mehr als 300 Dienstleistungen
an einem Ort zusammenführen.
Es hat die Art und Weise, wie
die Regierung Dienstleistungen
auf der Ebene von
Service-Centern erbringt,
radikal verändert.
- Traditionelle Wege sind
nicht mehr geeignet, um unsere
Dienstleistungen zu erbringen
und einen Zufriedenheitsgrad zu erreichen.
Aber wir wissen auch,
dass es nicht nur um Technologien geht.
Es geht auch um Organisationsstrukturen.
Es geht um menschliche
Ressourcen und wir versuchen,
ein geeignetes Umfeld zu schaffen,
um unsere Dienstleistungen
effektiv und effizient für
unsere Bürger zu erbringen.
- Worauf die Regierung einen
unglaublichen Wert gelegt hat,
ist die Erkenntnis, dass
jeder Mensch anders ist.
Und ein großartiges Erlebnis
ist oft nicht etwas, das
völlig reibungslos abläuft,
wie z.B. das Buchen eines Zugtickets.
Es ist nicht so schwierig
zu sagen, zu welchem
Bahnhof man muss, zu
welcher Zeit, von wo aus
man abfährt und wie viele
Passagiere dort sind.
Das ist ein sehr automatisierter Prozess,
der fast keine Variationen aufweist.
Aber wenn Sie versuchen,
Ihren Namen zu ändern
und tatsächlich die
Optionen, die Sie für eine
nicht verfügbar sind
oder wenn Sie versuchen,
Gesundheitsdienstleistungen
zu beanspruchen und Sie haben
zwei Kinder, die natürlich
geboren sind, eine ist adoptiert.
Das sind die Arten von
einzigartigen Situationen, die,
wenn Organisationen in der
Lage sind, damit effektiv
umzugehen, den Menschen ein
wirklich gutes Gefühl geben.
Denn es gibt ihnen das Gefühl, dass
sie tatsächlich verstehen,
dass es sehr persönliche
Anforderungen gibt, die die Bürger haben.
- Wenn Sie zu Hause sitzen,
wie ist Ihr Gefühl über die
Dienstleistungen, die Sie
von der Regierung erhalten?
Machen Sie sich Sorgen
darüber, etwas zu verpassen
oder zu vergessen, Ihre
Rechnungen zu bezahlen, Ihre
Nebenkostenabrechnungen, oder
fühlen Sie sich wohl, weil Sie
wissen, dass es automatisch
über Ihren digitalen Assistenten
abgewickelt wird, diese
Art von Niveau und diese
Art von Erfahrung ist
das, was wir anstreben,
wo ein Kunde sich keine
Sorgen machen muss,
dass alles im Hintergrund
in seinem Namen läuft.
- Die Inanspruchnahme staatlicher
Dienstleistungen irgendwo
auf der Welt ist normalerweise mit dem
Gedanken an Bürokratie und
viel Papierkram verbunden.
Ich denke, was hier anders
ist, ist, dass es einen
unglaublichen Fokus darauf
gab, sicherzustellen, dass
der Schmerz und die Reibung,
die normalerweise mit
der jährlichen Erneuerung
von Diensten verbunden sind,
weggenommen wurden.
Ob das nun die Erneuerung Ihres Autos
ist, die fast vollständig
eine digitale Transaktion
ist, ob das die jährliche nationale ID
ist oder ob das nur das Bezahlen
Ihres Parkplatzes über
Ihr Mobiltelefon ist.
Alles ist miteinander verknüpft.
Und das Schöne ist, dass
es eine einzige Portal-App
gibt, auf die Sie dann
zugreifen können, und egal
ob es sich um Krankenhäuser,
Bestattungsunternehmen
oder Behörden handelt,
all diese Informationen sind
nicht an einem Ort untergebracht.
- Meiner Umfrage zufolge sind drei Viertel
der CEOs der Meinung, dass das
Kundenerlebnis sehr wichtig
für ihr Unternehmen ist.
Aber in der Regierung gibt
es keine solche Umfrage.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele
Führungskräfte in der Regierung
denken, dass das Kundenerlebnis
oberste Priorität hat,
aber ich sage Ihnen,
dass es 10 Millionen
Regierungsmitarbeiter gibt und
dass es nicht für alle
oberste Priorität hat.
- Sagen wir also, Sie müssen an einen Ort
gehen, Sie müssen an einen
physischen Ort gehen.
Wie ist die Erfahrung,
wenn Sie dort ankommen?
Ist es überfüllt und chaotisch?
Wissen Sie, was zu tun ist?
Bekommen Sie einen guten Kundenservice?
Sprechen Sie mit Menschen,
die gut informiert sind,
und wenn sie selbst
Schwierigkeiten haben, Ihnen die
Informationen zu beschaffen,
haben sie Zugang zu Informationsmitteln,
die Ihnen als Mitglied der
Gemeinschaft helfen können.
Ich glaube, die Regierungen
beginnen jetzt, über
den gesamten Lebenszyklus
eines Prozesses nachzudenken.
Zum Beispiel,
um eine Kopie Ihrer
Geburtsurkunde zu erhalten.
Wenn Sie einen Antrag
für eine Genehmigung einreichen möchten,
die gerade so eine gewöhnliche Stadt-
oder Regierungstätigkeit ist,
sollte es nicht so schwer
sein, wie es heute ist.
Die Leute freuen sich nicht darauf
und die Erfahrung sollte besser sein.
Sie sollten in der Lage
sein und zunehmend auch
sein, eine Genehmigung online
zu beantragen, ohne dass Sie
zu einem Ort gehen und
eine Nummer ziehen müssen
und den halben Tag im
Büro der Regierung warten.
- In den Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten konzentrieren wir
uns auf das Kundenerlebnis
aus den Lebensinstanzen.
Wenn der Kunde zum Beispiel
ein neugeborenes Baby hat,
betrachten wir das als einen
Punkt im Leben, an dem er
staatliche Dienstleistungen
rund um ein neues Baby benötigt.
Deshalb haben wir begonnen, die Sache aus
der Perspektive der
Bündelung zu betrachten.
Anstatt dass ein Kunde also
nachschaut, welche Behörden
oder Behörden-Service-Center
er aufsuchen sollte, weiß
er einfach, welches Paket er haben möchte.
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel für einen der
Dienste, die wir haben.
Er heißt Mabrouk Ma
Yak, was Glückwunsch zu
Ihrem Neugeborenen bedeutet.
Und es hat mehr als sieben
Dienste in einem Schritt
und mehr als fünf Zahlungen
in einer Zahlung gebündelt.
Und alles, was mit diesem
Neugeborenen zu tun hat, bekommen
Sie jetzt mit diesem Bundle
innerhalb von drei Stunden.
- Wir bewegen uns jetzt von
einem Meilenstein-Einkaufsmodell
zu einem Non-Stop-Shopmodell.
In unseren Service-Centern
bieten wir unseren Bürgern
reaktive Dienste an, aber
jetzt haben wir ein neues
Projekt gestartet,
das sich "Mein Wachstum, mein
Regierungsprojekt" nennt.
Und es geht um die
Bereitstellung proaktiver Dienste
für unsere Bürger.
Dafür sind wir bereit, Beta weitgehend zu
nutzen, um die Erwartungen
unserer Bürger vorherzusagen.
Und regierungsintern
versuchen wir, auch die
Unternehmen in diesen Prozess einzubinden.
- Als Ergebnis der sich wirklich
schnell verändernden Welt
ändern sich auch die
Erwartungen der Bürger.
Die Bürger erwarten heute ein anderes
Niveau an Service auf Regierungsebene.
Die Erwartungen sind
eine Kombination aus dem,
was sie im privaten
Sektor, im Einzelhandel
und im Gesundheitswesen
sehen, und das führt
zu einem allgemeinen
Bedürfnis der Bürger, wenn
Sie so wollen, nach Service Excellence.
Die Bürger von heute, Sie
und ich, wir alle nutzen
Smartphones und Technologie,
um Entscheidungen zu treffen,
um auf Dienste zuzugreifen.
Und es ist sehr verbreitet,
einfach zu erwarten, dass jeder
Service auf einem Mobiltelefon
verfügbar sein sollte,
er sollte auf einem mobilen
Gerät verfügbar sein,
aber nicht alle Regierungen
waren in der Lage,
Services von einem Service-Center
auf online zu übertragen.
- Bei den meisten so
genannten Governance-Agenden
geht es in Wirklichkeit darum,
dass Regierungen den Menschen Dienste
durch Technologie zur Verfügung stellen.
So können wir Webseiten
der Regierung sehen,
auf die Sie zugreifen können,
Formulare zum Ausfüllen von Pässen
oder Lizenzen oder zum
Bezahlen von Steuern.
Das ist eine wirklich
interessante Änderung
der Managementstruktur.
Früher hatten die Regierungen
viele Beamte, viele Leute, die
für sie arbeiteten, um den
Papierkram zu erledigen.
Jetzt wurde der Aufwand und die
Last wieder auf die Bürger übertragen.
Es ist wie in den alten
Tagen, wenn Sie an einem
Meeting teilnehmen, schickt Ihnen jemand
den ganzen Papierkram im Voraus.
Sie mussten nichts tun, Sie haben nur den
Papierkram gelesen und ihn
zum Treffen mitgenommen.
Jetzt werden Ihnen die
Dateien digital per E-Mail
oder über ein anderes
Online-System zugeschickt, oder es
wird sogar von Ihnen
erwartet, dass Sie online
gehen, um diese Formulare
selbst herunterzuladen, sie dann
zu lesen und sie dann
vielleicht auszudrucken, weil
Sie sie vielleicht zur
Besprechung mitnehmen müssen.
Das ist also eine Verlagerung
der Arbeit von Regierungen
zu Bürgern oder von
Organisationen zu Mitarbeitern.
Ich hasse es, mich jeden
Tag auf drei oder vier
verschiedenen Websites anmelden zu müssen,
um Informationen zu erhalten,
während sie mir einfach
in einer anderen Form
geschickt werden könnten.
Die Standard-Rhetorik ist
natürlich, dass es für
Regierungen und Bürger
viel einfacher ist, bei
wichtigen Dingen, die sie
tun müssen, zu interagieren.
Und das hat zweifellos seine Vorteile, es
ist jetzt sehr einfach,
einen Passantrag online
zu stellen oder Ihre
Steuerformulare online einzureichen.
Der zweite Punkt ist jedoch,
und ich werde das Beispiel
unseres eigenen digitalen
Dienstes der Regierung verwenden.
Es gibt viele großartige
Dinge über gov.uk.
Wenn Sie jedoch auf der Website der
Regierung etwas über ein
Ministerium oder dessen
Aufgaben herausfinden möchten,
ist dies fast unmöglich.
Und ich denke, das ist ein Hinweis darauf,
dass es einen Unterschied
zwischen der Erbringung von
Regierungsdienstleistungen
und der Beziehung
zwischen Regierungen und Bürgern
und der Offenheit und Transparenz
in diesem Bereich gibt.
- Heute denke ich, dass die
Bürger Mitgestalter einer
Regierungserfahrung sind.
Es gibt eine Möglichkeit
für jeden von uns, Partner
zu sein und dabei zu
helfen, Dinge zu erledigen,
eine größere Offenheit zu erreiche,
Städte progressiver zu
machen und mehr Werkzeuge
für die Zusammenarbeit zu
erlangen, die es insbesondere
den Mitgliedern der Gemeinschaft erlauben,
an allem teilzunehmen, von der
Entscheidungsfindung bis hin
zu Design-Sitzungen und sogar
der Entwicklung von Lösungen.
Es gibt einige sehr
interessante Experimente mit der
Gemeinschaft, Kofinanzierung,
Identifizierung von Geldern
aus dem öffentlichen
und privaten Sektor, um
Projekte zu realisieren, die
aufgrund der Abhängigkeit von
rein öffentlichen Geldern nur
schwer in Gang zu bringen waren.
Wenn eine Regierung Daten
zur Verfügung stellt
und das Community-Mitglied
sagt, hey, ich könnte
eine Lösung mit diesen Daten bauen.
Wow, das ist eine tolle Beziehung,
das ist eine tolle Partnerschaft.
Wir haben jetzt Software-Ingenieure,
die antreten können, um
interessante Lösungen zu
erstellen oder um Daten sinnvoll
zu nutzen und die Analysen zu liefern, die
den Entscheidungsträgern helfen,
bessere Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Das ist eine Beziehung, für die wir noch
nie die Werkzeuge hatten,
um sie zu realisieren.
Eine gute demokratische
Regierungserfahrung ist kein
Zuschauersport, sondern
etwas, an dem Sie teilnehmen.
- Der Staat Washington ist eine
meiner bevorzugten
leistungsorientierten Organisationen.
Es gibt etwas, das sich
Ergebnisse Washington nennt.
Jede einzelne Kennzahl über
die Landesregierung ist online
verfügbar, Drill Downs, um
mehr Details zu erhalten.
Und wenn der Gouverneur
eine Ergebnisbesprechung
veranstaltet, ist die
Öffentlichkeit eingeladen.
Es wird live online gestreamt,
aber sie beziehen auch einen
oder zwei oder drei Kunden in
jedes einzelne Meeting ein.
Wenn es also um die Entwicklung der
Jugend geht, gibt es
tatsächlich Jugendliche, die
der Regierung ein Feedback geben, wie sich
die Dienste verbessern, wo sie
mehr Verbesserung brauchen.
Das ist also ein großartiges
Beispiel auf staatlicher Ebene.
Und im Moment sammeln 90 %
der Websites unserer
Bundesbehörden Kundenfeedback und
versuchen, sich iterativ zu verbessern.
- Mein Fazit ist, dass
es wirklich interessant
ist, was heute in der Welt passiert.
Die Menge an Daten, die täglich
generiert wird, ist einfach überwältigend.
Doch wenn Sie mit vielen
Unternehmen sprechen,
mit der Regierung, mit
dem privaten Sektor,
mit großen Unternehmen,
werden diese Ihnen sagen,
dass sie schlechte Daten
haben, Probleme mit
der Qualität, dass es
Lücken in den Daten gibt.
Es gibt ein Problem.
- Es gibt viele Altsysteme und
Daten, die da draußen sind,
die ziemlich schwierig zu erschließen
und an die Oberfläche zu bringen sind.
Wenn Sie etwas auf der
grünen Wiese bauen, ist es
viel einfacher, das von A bis Z zu tun.
Aber die Wahrheit ist, dass
viele Regierungsabteilungen
riesige Altlasten an
Informationssystemen haben,
die sie mit untraditionellen
Prozessen nutzen.
Die Schwierigkeit besteht also
darin, diese in einem Format
zusammenzufügen, bei dem der
Kunde keine Unebenheiten spürt.
Es ist, als würde man
einen Einkaufswagen über
ein Bahngleis schieben, ein
sehr holpriges Erlebnis.
Und was Sie versuchen, ist, all
diese Knoten aus der
Erfahrung herauszunehmen.
- In allen Quellen brauchen
Sie eine Form von Identität,
aber es ist Identität, als
gäbe es nur eine Identität.
Und ich nehme an, Sie
haben mehrere Identitäten,
die Sie verwenden können.
Ich werde also eine andere
Identität verwenden, um
mich anzumelden, z. B. in
meinen Google-Konten, die
ich dann z. B. für
Behördendienste verwende.
Ich hoffe, diese digitalen
Identitäten, mehrere Identitäten
gehören mir und werden
von mir kontrolliert.
- Der Staat Indiana hat
vor kurzem ein Single Sign
On geschaffen, so dass ich
meine Parkgenehmigung und meinen
Führerschein, Zertifizierungen,
alle staatlichen Aktivitäten,
die ich mit dem Staat mache,
unter einer ID abrufen kann.
Damit ich meine Informationen
nicht ständig neu eingeben
muss, ist das eine wunderbare
Art von One-Stop-Shop.
Aber wir sind noch weit
davon entfernt, dass wir in
der Lage sind, von der Bundesebene
über die Länderebene bis
hin zur lokalen Ebene
mit einer einzigen
Identität zu integrieren.
Und ich denke, es lohnt sich,
hier vorsichtig zu sein,
denn eine einzige
Identität in der Regierung
birgt das Risiko,
dass sie gehackt werden
könnte, und wenn dies durch den
privaten Sektor geschieht,
hat die Regierung nicht die Kontrolle und
kann sie nicht in der Weise überwachen,
wie es vielleicht notwendig wäre.
So haben wir zum Beispiel in den USA für
die Reisefähigkeit,
die Transportation Security
Administration ist für die
Ausstellung von TSA Pre-Check
verantwortlich, so dass sie
mich überprüfen und ich dann
in eine Schnellspur gehen kann.
Nun, es gibt auch eine
privatwirtschaftliche
Einrichtung, die das tut.
Was ist die grundlegende
Rolle der Regierung?
Sollte es die Regierung
sein, die sagt, wer in ein
Flugzeug einsteigen kann
und sicher reisen darf und wer nicht.
- Wenn Sie der Regierung
Ihre gesamte Identität
überlassen, was könnte sie damit tun?
Ich vergleiche das oft
mit den Geschehnissen
in Ruanda, wo der
Einsatz älterer digitaler
Technologien, z. B.
des Radios, viele Teile
des dortigen Völkermordes
effizienter ermöglichte.
Wenn also eine Regierung die
Identität eines jeden Menschen
kennt und weiß, wo er wohnt
und alles über ihn weiß,
was kann sie dann mit diesen
Informationen anfangen?
Bei Migranten geht es sehr oft um
Fragen wie z.B.
Wetterqualifikationen, die in einem
Land gewonnen wurden und mit denen Spiele
in einem anderen Land
kompatibel sein können.
Stellen Sie sich vor,
jeder hätte eine digitale
Identität, die er mitnehmen
könnte, so dass Sie,
wenn Sie von Kenia nach
Südafrika oder von Haiti nach
Brasilien ziehen,
tatsächlich Ihre Identität
mitnehmen können.
Ich denke, das eröffnet wirklich
spannende Möglichkeiten,
nicht nur für Migranten,
sondern auch für Regierungen.
Wenn wir globale Vereinbarungen
darüber treffen könnten, was
ihre Parameter und was die
Berechtigungsnachweise in der
digitalen Identität
bedeuten, könnte das wirklich
von Vorteil sein.
- Es wird also nicht die eine Technologie
sein, die das Identitätsthema lösen wird.
Es wird eine Kombination sein, und in
diesem Moment versuchen wir
wirklich herauszufinden, wie
wir eine digitale Identität
mit datenschutzfreundlichen Technologien
wie Zero Knowledge Proofs
oder Multi-Party-Computation
kombinieren können.
Ich denke, das ist ein
wirklich interessanter Bereich,
der auf internationaler Ebene
erforscht werden sollte.
- Wir in Estland glauben,
dass die digitale
Identität das Rückgrat von allem ist.
Jede Person sollte eine Identität haben,
die ihr physisch und digital entspricht.
So kommuniziert jeder Este
mit der Regierung unter
Verwendung seiner digitalen
Identität, was bedeutet, dass er
alles, von Kontoauszügen
über Steuern bis hin zur
Registrierung der Geburt,
unter Verwendung der
digitalen Identität erledigt.
Und wir können uns unser Leben
nicht mehr anders vorstellen.
- Es war tatsächlich schön für
uns als estnische Regierung,
diese Lernerfahrung, um
Erfahrungen im Fokus zu haben.
Ich will hier ganz
ehrlich sein, ich glaube,
wir waren in unseren
Anfangsjahren sehr technisch und
ingenieurmäßig orientiert, vor
allem in dem Sinne, dass wir
gesehen haben, okay, wie viel
besser, wie viel effizienter
wir sein können, wenn wir die
Dinge funktional aufbauen und
zum Beispiel Dienste online stellen,
was auch immer die Erfahrung ist.
Jetzt kommen wir wirklich
zu dem Punkt, der
es auf die nächste Stufe
gebracht hat, natürlich
muss die Erfahrung im
Vordergrund stehen, denn sonst
haben wir keine Leute, die es benutzen.
Und so geht es natürlich weit über Fragen
des schönen, sauberen Designs
einer Online-Umgebung hinaus.
Unser Hauptaugenmerk liegt
darauf, wie wir den Prozess, die
Arbeit der Regierung zur
besten Erfahrung machen können.
Und in vielen Fällen geht es für
uns darum, wie wir radikal
vereinfachen können,
denn die beste Erfahrung,
zumindest was den
Studenten betrifft,
ist, wenn es keine gibt,
wenn das für mich passiert.
Als Este ist es sehr schwer,
Ratschläge zu erteilen und
physische Service-Center,
denn für uns hat die digitale
Reise bedeutet, sie
weitgehend loszuwerden.
- Es gibt die Steuerbehörde,
die einen physischen
Standard hat und vielleicht die Post.
Aber ansonsten, wenn wir über
staatliche Dienstleistungen
sprechen, sind diese zu 99% online.
- Wenn Sie keinen Zugang
zum Digitalen haben,
egal auf welche Weise, weil Sie keine
Verbindung haben, haben Sie keinen Strom.
Sie werden durch die
Bereitstellung digitaler
Dienste weiter an den Rand gedrängt.
Das klassische Beispiel ist
die Idee der Smart Cities.
Ich sage oft, dass allein
das Wort "Smart Cities"
eigentlich impliziert, dass
Dörfer ziemlich dumm sind.
Eine der größten Herausforderungen
besteht also darin, dass
man in einem kleinen, dicht
besiedelten Gebiet mit
voller Konnektivität nicht das
liefern kann, was man kann.
Deshalb ist es so wichtig, in
erster Linie Zugang zu haben.
- Und nicht alle unsere Bürger
sind technologisch bewandert.
Deshalb brauchen wir unsere Service-Center
in allen Teilen unseres Landes.
Außerdem haben wir mobile Busse.
Diese Busse sind speziell
mit verschiedenen
Technologien ausgestattet.
Wir haben diese Busse in die abgelegenen
Gebiete geschickt, in denen
wir keine ASAS-Servicezentren
haben, um unsere Bürger zu bedienen.
Und auch wir haben Freiwillige.
- Der menschliche Faktor innerhalb der
Regierungserfahrung ist
ein primärer Faktor.
Aus allen Perspektiven, würde ich sagen.
Ob es sich also um eine
Kundenperspektive handelt
oder um die Perspektive
eines Regierungsmitarbeiters,
selbst die Mitarbeiter, die
an der Erbringung von
Regierungsdienstleistungen arbeiten,
haben wir auf ihr
Glücksniveau hin untersucht.
Wir haben uns angesehen,
wie sie verstehen,
was Kunden wollen.
Deshalb haben wir eine Reihe
von Schulungen durchgeführt.
Es ist ein Training zur
Kundenzufriedenheit, bei dem wir uns
die Mitarbeiter an der Frontlinie ansehen,
die die Dienstleistungen erbringen.
Wir haben sie darin geschult, wie sie ihre
Geschäfte so führen können,
dass der Kunde zufriedener
ist, und gleichzeitig haben
wir uns die Vorgesetzten
dieser staatlichen Service-Center
angesehen, die wir in den
Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten das Zentrum
für Kundenzufriedenheit nennen.
Und wir haben sie darin
geschult, wie man ein Team
von Kundenzufriedenheitsbeauftragten
beaufsichtigt.
- Ich bin nicht dafür, absolut
100%ig jeden Regierungsdienst
physisch abzuschaffen, denn
wir sehen, dass in einigen
Regionen Estlands dies die
einzige Form der Kommunikation
ist, die einige dieser
Menschen tatsächlich haben und
sie genießen diese
Formen der Kommunikation.
Sie gehen gerne zur Post, aber in Bezug
auf das Stadtleben, in
Bezug auf das tatsächliche
Gehen zum Finanzamt und
das dreistündige Warten auf
den Papierstapel, das sollte
absolut eliminiert werden.
- Die Art und Weise der Gestaltung
von Regierungsdienstleistungen
ist wirklich klar.
Wir brauchen durchgängig
eine Vorlage für Exzellenz.
Wir brauchen etwas, das
sich leicht anpassen
lässt und einfach eingesetzt werden kann.
Wenn ein Land z.B. ein
Exzellenzmodell hat, ist
dieses Modell in der Lage,
über verschiedene Gruppen,
über verschiedene Abteilungen
und Ministerien hinweg
repliziert zu werden.
Das ist genau das, was gebraucht wird.
Das GX-Programm in den
Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten ist ein
hervorragendes Beispiel dafür.
Exzellente Regierungsdienstleistungen
haben für die
Regierung der VAE oberste Priorität.
Dinge wie das Tweeten über
die Rankings von staatlichen
Service-Centern ist in den
VAE nicht sehr ungewöhnlich,
und das ist die Art, wie
die Führung das Land führt.
- GX wurde mit der Vision
und dem Verstand geschaffen,
die Aufmerksamkeit der Menschen,
die an Dienstleistungen
arbeiten, zu lenken,
unabhängig von der Art der
Kunden oder der Persona
des Kunden, wir müssen
uns auf die Erfahrung
des Kunden konzentrieren.
Wer ist nun Teil der GX, jeder.
Es könnte also der private Sektor
sein, könnten Investoren,
Startups, Unternehmer sein.
Wer Teil der GX-Plattform sein könnte,
hat mehrere Aspekte: Wir haben das
Government Services Forum,
das Führungskräfte aus
der ganzen Welt an einen Tisch
bringt, um über Government
Services zu diskutieren.
Wir haben die GX Online-Plattform, die
die Wissensbasis teilt,
wie Regierungen auf
der ganzen Welt die
Kundenerfahrung verbessern.
Wir haben auch die GX-Gespräche.
Daher konzentrierten sich
die GX-Gespräche auch darauf,
Vordenker aus verschiedenen
Bereichen zusammenzubringen,
um über Kundenerfahrungen zu
sprechen, sei es die digitale
Erfahrung oder auch die
physische Erfahrung oder
sogar Erfahrungen, die
keinen Touchpoint haben.
Wenn Sie also zum Beispiel
zu Hause sitzen, wie ist
Ihr Gefühl über das, was Sie
von der Regierung bekommen?
Haben Sie Angst, etwas zu
verpassen oder zu vergessen,
Ihre Rechnungen, Ihre
Nebenkostenabrechnungen zu
bezahlen, oder sind Sie bequem, weil Sie
wissen, dass es automatisch
verarbeitet wird.
- Die VAE sind eine beeindruckende Nation.
Sie haben den Vorteil, dass sie schnell,
wendig und agil sind in der Art
und Weise, wie sie Initiativen angehen.
Außerdem haben sie eine Führung, die
wirklich daran glaubt, digital zu werden
und die vierte industrielle
Revolution zu übernehmen.
Ich denke, wenn man diese
Zutaten zusammenfügt,
erhält man eine sehr
einzigartige Umgebung aufgrund
der Plattform, die
durch die Investition in
dieses futuristische
Denken geschaffen wurde.
- Es ist nicht nur ihre Vision und ihr
Gerede, sondern sie bauen
Dinge und tun Dinge.
Ich habe diese Dinge in Dubai aus
erster Hand erleben
können. Zum Beispiel ihr
Konzept rund um die
zukünftige Polizeistation.
Es ist ein schönes Erlebnis.
Die Menschen fühlen sich sicher.
Und vieles davon geschieht
durch den Einsatz digitaler
Technologien, Unterstützung
durch die richtigen Ressourcen
per Videokonferenz, was
ich unglaublich fand.
Sie sehen eine Menge
Experimente und Prototypen, Sie
sehen sehr kühne Projekte,
alles vom intelligenten Dubai
bis hin zur papierlosen
Gesellschaft, wodurch die Kosten
der Regierung geringer werden,
die Daten genauer werden
- all die Vorteile, die
wir erwarten würden.
Einer der größten Vorteile ist der
Verzicht auf das älteste Papier.
Sie tun die Dinge, sie demonstrieren,
sie experimentieren, sie
helfen anderen Gemeinden
und Städten und Regierungen auf der
ganzen Welt zu sehen, was möglich ist.
Um diese Erkenntnisse mit der Welt zu
teilen, möchte ich, dass Sie Dinge wie
das GX-Forum schaffen,
das zu einer globalen
Plattform wird, um zu
sagen: "Hey, was gibt es für
verschiedene Möglichkeiten
einer Regierungserfahrung?"
Wir müssen in der Lage sein, Kanäle zu
schaffen, die diese Best
Practices, die Dinge, die
gut laufen und vielleicht
sogar die Lehren aus
den Dingen, die nicht immer so gut laufen,
aufnehmen und mit Regierungen
in jeder Ecke der Welt teilen.
- Ich denke also, dass
es wichtig ist, dass
es ein internationales
Gespräch ist und offen gesagt
ein persönliches Gespräch,
denn wir sind alle beschäftigt.
Wenn wir nur versuchen,
uns per Telefon oder
Webinar zu treffen, werden
wir allerdings abgelenkt.
Aber wenn man sich physisch
mit anderen Menschen
zusammentut, stellt man die
Art von Verbindungen her,
die andauern und die es uns
erlauben, den Ball weiter
voranzutreiben, unser
Denken weiter zu verfeinern
und uns gegenseitig herauszufordern,
dieses Gefühl von fast
so etwas wie einem gesunden
Wettbewerb unter Gleichaltrigen,
wie, oh, ich werde etwas zu
sagen haben, wenn ich wieder
mit dieser Gruppe zusammenkomme,
was habe ich getan?
Was bringe ich auf den Tisch?
Ich denke also, das ist ein echter Wert,
den wir in dieser Gruppe sehen können.
- Es ist wirklich notwendig,
Experimente innerhalb der
eigenen Organisation durchzuführen,
aber ansonsten ist es
immer noch kompliziert, diese
Diskussionen mit anderen
Partnern zu führen,
die Dienste entwickeln.
Sie müssen also ein wenig innerhalb
Ihrer eigenen Organisation
testen und erforschen.
Sie müssen Ihre Mitarbeiter
schulen, es gibt kaum
Projekte, Sie müssen
kaum zusammenarbeiten.
Es ist also wirklich
wichtig zu lernen, wie
man aus Koalitionen und
ich Art von Vereinbarungen,
die wir brauchen, die
rechtlichen Fragen rund um
diese Kooperationen, die
Governance-Modelle aufbauen kann.
- Natürlich ist es sehr schwierig,
unsere Ideen so umzusetzen.
Denn jedes Land hat seine
eigenen Kulturen, sowohl in
Bezug auf die Tradition
als auch auf die Umwelt.
Und Sie können sehen, wie sie in
dieser Umgebung herausgefordert
werden und wie sie
diese Probleme während des
Implementierungsprozesses lösen.
- Initiativen wie diese
neigen oft dazu, die
beste globale Lösung finden zu wollen.
Aber diese Ideen
entwickeln sich weiter, die
Beziehung zu den Bürgerstaaten
entwickelt sich weiter.
Die Technologie entwickelt sich weiter.
Also ein bisschen mehr,
denke ich, Selbstkritik,
und nicht immer positiv über einige der
Aktivitäten, die passieren,
denn Technologie kann für
Gutes und für Schlechtes verwendet werden.
Und es geht darum, wie
unmittelbar diese im Interesse
der Bürger sind.
Für mich sind die Bürger
eigentlich wichtiger als die Regierungen.
Regierungen sollten ihren Bürgern dienen.
- Wir haben für meine
Residenzerfahrungen gelernt,
zu versuchen, sich in die Lage
des Anwenders zu versetzen.
Denn wir sehen sehr oft, dass
genau das den Regierungsbeamten fehlt.
Sie sitzen also in
ihren Silos und sprechen
nicht mit den Anwendern,
sie verstehen nicht die
Bedürfnisse der Anwender im
Zeitalter der Smartphones und
all der privatwirtschaftlichen Dienste,
die wir eigentlich ständig konsumieren.
Wir können von unseren
Regierungen nicht erwarten,
dass sie hinterherhinken.
Wir glauben in Estland,
dass Regierungen niemals
mit privaten Unternehmen
konkurrieren können, und das
sollten sie auch nicht,
aber Regierungen sind
diejenigen, die staatliche
Dienstleistungen anbieten müssen.
Es ist also an der Zeit, tatsächlich mit
den Trends mitzugehen,
was in der Welt passiert.
Das globale Star-Rating-Programm, ist das
erste seiner Art, das staatliche
Dienstleistungszentren
wie ein Kartell bewertet.
So wie Sie in ein Hotel
gehen und sehen, dass dieses Hotel
ein Fünf-Sterne-Hotel
ist und Sie verstehen,
welche Erfahrung Sie von
einem Fünf-Sterne-Hotel
bekommen werden, so wurde
das gleiche, ähnliche Konzept
auf Dienstleistungszentren
der Regierung angewendet.
Hassan Chef Hamad, hat uns
angeleitet, die Regierung der
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
so effizient wie Banken zu
machen und rund um die Uhr
zu arbeiten wie Flughäfen.
Seitdem dieses Programm
eingeführt wurde, haben wir
die Früchte dieses
Programms erkannt, indem wir
gesehen haben, dass sich das
Kundenzufriedenheitszentrum in
den letzten acht Jahren
deutlich verbessert hat.
- Das Edelman Trust
Barometer stuft die VAE sehr
hoch ein, es ist nicht das zweithöchste in
der Region und eines der höchsten in der
Welt, ich denke mit den Fokuszentren.
Die Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate haben ihre
Regierungsdienste schon
immer so gestaltet, dass sie
eigentlich als Ermöglicher
für die Gesellschaft
angesehen werden.
Heute blicken die VAE
nach vorne und sagen,
ich will noch mehr als noch besser werden.
Ich möchte noch kundenorientierter sein.
Ich möchte sicherstellen,
dass die Dienstleistungen
meiner Regierung nicht nur die besten
der Welt sind, sondern auch die
zufriedenstellendsten für
die Menschen, die sie wählen.
Und tatsächlich, wie kann
ich ihr Leben verbessern?
Wie kann ich tatsächlich einen Mehrwert
für ihr Leben schaffen?
Und das ist etwas,
das wir tagtäglich erleben.
Diese Kultur der Transparenz, die sich in
den VAE mehr und mehr durchsetzt.
Um die Besten der Welt zu sein,
müssen wir auch den Spiegel vorhalten.
Und das ist etwas, das Sie
passieren sehen und von
dem Sie denken,
dass die Regierung mit
gutem Beispiel vorangeht.
- Die Zukunft des GX-Programms durch
das Büro des Premierministers in
den Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten ist stark.
Es ist etwas, das greifbar ist.
Es ist etwas,
das von jedem staatlichen
Dienstleistungsprogramm
auf der Welt entwickelt
und übernommen werden kann.
Aber es braucht Arbeit, es braucht Arbeit,
denn die Implementierung
dieser Dinge ist komplex.
Sie brauchen Stakeholder, die
sich auf diese Dinge einigen.
Sie brauchen die Zustimmung der Menschen,
die Regierungen führen.
Und das sind einige der
Herausforderungen, mit denen andere
Regierungen konfrontiert werden könnten,
wenn sie dieses Programm einführen.
Wir leben in einer Ära der
Unterbrechung, der sich
schnell ändernden Erwartungen.
Um die Welt zu einem besseren
Ort zu machen, müssen
wir das Spiel auf eine
andere Art und Weise
spielen, egal ob es sich
um GX oder ein anderes
Programm auf der Ebene
der Regierungsbehörden handelt,
es braucht das Engagement
der Führung dieser Länder,
dieser Abteilungen und Gruppen.
- Dies ist also eine erstaunliche Zeit.
Es gibt so viel Potenzial
und wir brauchen zwei Dinge.
Wir müssen, Nummer eins, zuhören
und Nummer zwei, handeln.
Und wenn man diese beiden Dinge
zusammennimmt, macht das
einen großen Unterschied.
So hat in den USA die Veteranenverwaltung,
die ehemalige Militärangehörige betreut,
die jetzt wieder im Land sind, eine
Umfrage zur Kundenzufriedenheit
gestartet, und es
stellte sich heraus, dass Menschen, die
an der Umfrage teilnahmen
und Feedback gaben,
viermal zufriedener mit der
Regierung waren als andere.
Wir wissen jetzt noch nicht,
ob ein Teil davon eine
Stichprobenverzerrung ist,
dass diejenigen, die sich
entschieden haben, die
Umfrage zu beantworten,
zufriedener waren.
Aber für mich sagt es auch, dass es
Macht hat, einfach nach
Feedback zu fragen.
Wenn Sie die Öffentlichkeit einbeziehen,
werden sie begeisterter.
Die Stadt Santa Monica, Kalifornien
hat einen Wohlfühlindex.
Sie haben beschlossen,
dass der Zweck dieser Stadt
darin besteht, das Wohlergehen
der Menschen zu unterstützen.
Eines der Dinge, die sie getan
haben, ist Social Media Sentiment Mining.
So können sie anhand der öffentlich
zugänglichen Informationen
auf Facebook und Twitter
erkennen, welche Nachbarschaften
angezeigt werden.
Welche Stadtteile sind
unter Stress, welche
Stadtteile haben Geldsorgen und wie kann
die Stadt wirklich etwas dagegen tun.
Wir haben jetzt eine
Drogenbehandlung in den Gefängnissen,
weil die Menschen, die aus
den Gefängnissen kamen,
ein 120-mal höheres Risiko
hatten, an einer Drogenüberdosis
zu sterben als die
durchschnittliche Person.
So können wir jetzt Interventionen
in unseren Gefängnissen
durchführen, weil der
Datenansatz uns erlaubt hat,
gezielt zu arbeiten.
Wenn die Gemeindemitglieder
sich beteiligen und der
Regierung helfen können, zu entscheiden,
wohin das Geld geht.
Als das Volk die Entscheidungen traf,
gab es mehr Investitionen in die
Gesundheit, mehr
Investitionen in die Bildung.
Und einige dieser frühen Städte, die dies
einsetzten, zeigten in
fünf, zehn Jahren eine
geringere Kindersterblichkeit.
Ich denke, wir werden ein
viel höheres Vertrauen
in die Regierung haben,
denn mit all diesen
neuen Möglichkeiten, die
Öffentlichkeit einzubeziehen,
gibt es ungenutzte Ideen und
Ressourcen und das Potenzial,
die Regierung wirklich
viel besser zu machen, als sie es je war.
- Wir planen, personalisierte
Dienste für unsere Bürger
zu implementieren, aus
jedem Land, von jedem
Ort, vom Ergebnis und den Barrieren.
Und um dafür zugänglich und verfügbar zu
sein, müssen wir auch neue
Technologien implementieren,
AI Machine Learning, Deep
Learning und andere Technologien.
Jetzt haben wir ein gemeinsames
Cloud-basiertes System für
die Dokumentenablage
implementiert, das uns hilft,
die Kosten für die Erstellung
Erstellung dieser Dienste zu reduzieren
und die Prozesse zu optimieren.
- Die Regierungen der
Zukunft werden sich mehr auf
den Zweck und weniger auf
Dienstleistungen konzentrieren.
Die Dienste werden durchgeführt.
Künstliche Intelligenz,
maschinelles Lernen, wird die
meisten der zu erbringenden
Dienstleistungen übernehmen.
Wir werden uns mehr darauf konzentrieren,
über unsere Zukunft nachzudenken,
wie wir das Leben als
Nation vergrößern können,
als Gemeinschaft werden die
Regierungen viel mehr zeitliche
Möglichkeiten und viel höhere
Vorsicht haben, wenn es um die
Lebensqualität geht,
wenn es um die Zukunft
der Regierung geht.
Viele der Probleme, die
wir heute kennen, viele
der Themen, die Sie
heute zu lösen versuchen,
wird es in 10 Jahren nicht mehr geben.
Wir alle werden in unseren Fähigkeiten
als menschliche Wesen erweitert werden.
Wir werden in der Lage sein,
mehr für weniger zu tun,
aber wir werden auch in der
Lage sein, uns tatsächlich auf
die Bereiche zu konzentrieren,
in denen wir den größten
Unterschied machen und den
größten Einfluss ausüben können,
nicht in Bezug auf die kleinen Dinge,
die um uns herum passieren,
sondern in Bezug auf die
Bereicherung des Lebens und wie wir
kontinuierlich Fortschritt
vorantreiben können.
- Ich glaube, dass KI definitiv
der nächste Zyklus der
großen Revolution in der
Technologie sein wird und was
wir damit machen können,
sind eine Menge Produkte
und Dienstleistungen,
die in der Vergangenheit
nicht möglich waren.
Aber ich glaube nicht,
dass der KI-Algorithmus
eines Tages empfindungsfähig
wird und aufwacht und dann
herausfindet, dass die Menschen
ausgerottet werden müssen.
Lassen Sie uns pragmatischer
und realistischer sein und
machen Sie sich keine
Sorgen über den Scifi-Teil.
Der Teil der KI, der
wirklich aufregend ist,
ist am hilfreichsten für Firmenanwender
oder Unternehmensmitarbeiter.
Der erste ist das Konzept
des digitalen Zwillings.
Das Konzept des digitalen
Zwillings besteht
darin, dass ein Assistent Seite an
Seite mit dem Menschen arbeitet, um
die Qualität der Arbeit zu verbessern,
indem alle banalen manuellen Aufgaben an
die KI und die Automatisierung
übertragen werden.
Damit der Mensch sich
tatsächlich auf die Dinge
konzentriert, auf die er sich
konzentrieren sollte, nicht
auf das Abheften von
Papieren, nicht auf das
Durchforsten von Dingen und
den Versuch, 1000 Seiten
zu indizieren, was alles von Maschinen
erledigt werden sollte.
Und der digitale Zwilling sollte diese
Workflow-Automatisierung für
den Menschen bereitstellen, um
effektiver und effizienter zu werden.
- Viele der Dienste werden
globale Dienste sein.
Und darauf oder daneben
werden Sie einen lokalen
Geschmack haben, aber was
ich sehe, und zum Beispiel
sind es die Blockchain-Projekte,
die Registrierung von
Diplomen, wird jetzt von
den Ländern selbst gemacht.
Ich erwarte, dass dies eine
globale Oberfläche sein wird.
Wir bringen Menschen aus
all diesen Koalitionen und
all diesen Gemeinschaften zusammen,
um an diesen Herausforderungen
zu arbeiten, die hauptsächlich
globale Herausforderungen sind.
Und ich denke, im Moment
ist der erste Schritt,
diese Experten zusammenzubringen,
sie brauchen einander,
zum Beispiel die Blockchain-Experten,
sie brauchen mehr und
mehr Daten, und deshalb
brauchen sie die Experten aus
der Big Data-Arbeitsgruppe,
aber auch die Datenexperten aus
der Arbeitsgruppe für
künstliche Intelligenz.
Der nächste Schritt ist also
der Aufbau von
Bruderkooperationen weltweit.
Und ich hoffe, dass die
Niederlande für viele
Dienste das Tor zu Europa sein können.
- Die Zukunft der staatlichen
Dienstleistungen sollte etwas
sein, das passiert, ohne
dass der Kunde danach fragt.
Wir wissen, was die Kunden wollen,
warum geben wir es ihnen nicht?
Warum gehen wir nicht
zum Kunden, anstatt einen
Kunden zu uns kommen zu lassen? Wir wollen
es mehr mit der digitalen
Erfahrung in Verbindung
bringen, die Kunden heute
beim Online-Shopping haben, wo
sie Empfehlungen bekommen, was
sie kaufen sollen, basierend
auf ihren vorherigen Suchen
zur Jahreszeit, wir wollen
etwas Ähnliches sein und
vielleicht sogar noch proaktiver.
Wir sind uns bewusst,
dass sich die Art und
Weise, wie Bildung vermittelt
werden soll, ändern wird.
Wir sind uns bewusst, dass
sich das Gesundheitswesen
verändern wird. All diese
Dienstleistungen müssen
auf eine Art und Weise integriert werden,
die es für den Kunden nahtlos macht.
- Wir haben die meisten
unserer Dienste bereits
online gestellt, aber jetzt geht es darum,
die Qualität der Dienste
tatsächlich zu messen.
Wie funktionieren sie?
Was könnte verbessert werden?
Was ist der Weg dahinter, das
meiste kann man online machen, aber
wir haben immer noch viele Relikte dabei.
Als wir in Estland unsere
Dienste für Nicht-Bürger
mit der e-Residency geöffnet
haben, bedeutet das, dass
wir von Zeit zu Zeit
einige estnische Dokumente
für Ausländer in unseren
Systemen auftauchen lassen.
Das ist etwas, das bearbeitet werden muss.
Wir arbeiten auf die Vorstellung hin,
diese nahtlosen
Hintergrunddienste zu haben.
Sobald Sie geboren sind,
kennen wir bereits Ihren Namen.
Wir kennen Ihr Geburtsdatum.
Wir wissen eine ganze
Reihe von Dingen über Sie.
Dasselbe gilt zum
Beispiel für die Medizin.
Wir sehen uns einige
Möglichkeiten an, mit denen
wir vorhersagen können, welche
Krankheiten Sie haben könnten
oder ob Sie genetisch
bedingt sind und ähnliches.
- Wir waren sehr pragmatisch
und haben gesagt: "Lasst uns
herausfinden, wie wir dieses Problem
organisatorisch lösen können,
ohne dass wir dabei die
richtigen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
für die Technologie treffen.
Also diese Art der
Herangehensweise, um Probleme
zu beheben und sie zu lösen.
Und es ist ein sehr
ingenieurmäßiger Weg, auch
wenn das Design ein Teil davon ist.
Und zum anderen haben wir von
der Tatsache profitiert, dass
wir in diesem Sinne offensichtlich
ein kleines Land sind.
Und die Größe spielt nicht
wirklich eine Rolle für den
Gesichtspunkt, wie viele
Menschen leben, sondern nur die,
ich würde sagen, dass wir als kleines Land
eine sehr schlanke Regierung haben,
was die Art und Weise betrifft,
wie Entscheidungen getroffen werden.
Und ich denke, wenn die Länder mich oft
fragen, okay, was macht uns
nicht ein bisschen flinker,
weil die Entscheidungsfindung
schneller ist und nicht zu
viele Regierungsebenen zu
konsultieren sind und so weiter.
Das hat es uns also ermöglicht,
ein ganzes Stück weiter zu kommen.
Und ich habe auch in
größeren Ländern gesehen,
wenn einige Entscheidungsprozesse
gestrafft werden,
natürlich in einem demokratischen Kontext,
dann kann man Sprünge machen.
Da sich die Technik schnell bewegt,
müssen Sie auch schneller
mitziehen können.
- Was die Welt wirklich
verändert, ist, wenn
aufgeklärte progressive
Regierungen in der Lage sind,
sich leicht mit aufgeklärten
aktiven Bürgern zu
verbinden, denn das ist eine starke Kraft.
Wenn Sie diese beiden Dinge
zusammenbringen, können
wir einige wirklich
erstaunliche Dinge tun.
Diese Art von Spannung,
die zwischen Gemeinden
und Regierungen besteht,
weil die Gemeinden große
Erwartungen haben, dass die
Regierungen sich anstrengen,
aber sie kämpfen damit, diese
Erwartungen zu erfüllen.
In einer digitalen Welt
können Sie konsistenter
liefern und Zugang zu
Informationen und Daten
erhalten, wenn sie benötigt
werden. Sie schaffen
einen nahtloseren Kanal
zwischen den Daten, die
von der Regierung erstellt
oder gesammelt werden,
und dem Wunsch, darauf
zuzugreifen, einfach weil
wir wissen wollen, was die Regierung über
uns sammelt, aber auch,
um bessere Entscheidungen
treffen und Lösungen entwickeln zu können.
In Zukunft wird es einen viel
höheren Grad an Automatisierung geben.
Und das wird sowohl in der
digitalen Welt, also dem Einsatz von
künstlicher Intelligenz,
aber auch durch Robotik sein.
Und so werden wir Fragen darüber haben,
was das für die menschliche
Erfahrung bedeutet.
Was bedeutet das für Arbeitsplätze?
Was bedeutet das für die
persönliche Verbindung, die
wir zwischen einer Person
und einem Anbieter haben?
Wir werden also alle positiven Seiten der
Automatisierung und der
künstlichen Intelligenz sehen.
Wir müssen uns auch bewusst sein, was
das letztlich für uns
als Menschen bedeutet.
Wir müssen entscheiden,
was wir dagegen tun wollen.
In den nächsten 10 bis 20 Jahren wird
es mehr Veränderungen
geben als in den letzten
100 Jahren, wenn es um Erfahrungen mit der
Regierung geht, wird es eine
bemerkenswerte Zeit sein.
- All die verschiedenen
Methoden, die heute zur Verfügung
stehen, einschließlich des
GX-Programms, sind erstaunlich.
Sie können ändern, wie
die Bürger bedient werden.
Sie können die Art und Weise
ändern, wie Bürger wie Sie und
ich Zugang zu Dienstleistungen
auf Regierungsebene
in dem Land unserer Wahl haben.
Ich glaube wirklich,
dass Regierungen GX als
ein Programm betrachten
müssen, das eine neue
Welle der Energie bringen
kann, das Effizienz
und Verantwortlichkeit in
ihre Regierung bringen kann.
- Die Vereinten Nationen sagen voraus,
dass die Weltbevölkerung
bis 2050 9,8 Milliarden
Menschen erreichen wird.
Das bedeutet, dass mehr Erwartungen
an Regierungen gestellt werden,
um den Bürgern besser zu dienen
und bessere Erfahrungen zu schaffen.
Das bedeutet eine
komplexere Welt mit neuen
Interessengruppen, neuen Herausforderungen
und neuen Reaktionsgeschwindigkeiten.
Im Jahr 2020 Kampf der Menschheit,
eine neue Herausforderung,
viele Regierungen kämpften
mit der Pandemie und doch
gelang es vielen über die
Erwartungen hinaus, die Bedrohung
durch die Pandemie zu verwalten,
zu kontrollieren und zu beseitigen.
Eine Sache, die alle reaktionsschnellen
und erfolgreichen
Regierungen auszeichnete,
war ihre Fähigkeit, schnell
zu reagieren, mit den Bürgern
in Kontakt zu treten
und sich auf den Erfolg
zu konzentrieren und gleichzeitig
in die Zukunft zu blicken.
Es sind diese Regierungen,
Denker, Führer und Wegbereiter,
die dabei sind, eine
bessere Welt zu schaffen.
- Wenn Sie glauben, dass es
einen Gesellschaftsvertrag
zwischen den Regierten
und der Regierung gibt,
dann müssen die Regierungen
bei der Bereitstellung
von Dienstleistungen
berücksichtigen, was die Menschen
wirklich von dieser
Beziehung haben wollen.
- Manchmal funktioniert
die Lösung, die an einem
Ort funktioniert, an einem anderen nicht.
Ich denke, es ist eine
echte Führungsqualifikation,
wenn man sehr neugierig auf die Geschichte
und die Kulturen ist, in denen man
arbeitet, um die Dienstleistungen
auf die jeweiligen
Bewohner oder Bürger
abzustimmen, denen man dient.
- Der Ansatz, Dienstleistungen
von außen nach innen und
nicht von innen nach außen
zu erbringen, bedeutet
einen Paradigmenwechsel in
der Art und Weise, wie die
Regierung traditionell Politik
entwickelt und umsetzt und
dann über die Erbringung von
Dienstleistungen nachdenkt.
- Die Herausforderungen,
mit denen Regierungen konfrontiert sind,
sind nicht mehr technischer
Natur. Die sind gelöst.
Die Probleme, mit denen Regierungen
heute konfrontiert sind,
drehen sich eher chaotischere
Probleme, wie z.B.
die Frage: Wie lösen wir Obdachlosigkeit?
Wie können wir die
Lebensmittelversorgung verbessern?
Wie können wir die Lebensqualität
der Menschen verbessern?
- Wir begannen mit der
öffentlichen Politik und
konzentrierten uns sehr auf
Märkte und Marktversagen und wie
die Regierung Probleme mit
Marktversagen lösen musste.
Ich denke, das ist
immer noch eine wichtige
Sache, aber ich denke, wir
müssen jetzt darüber hinausgehen
und verstehen, dass Gleichheit
und Gerechtigkeit wirklich
wichtige Faktoren sind, die
wir berücksichtigen müssen
und herausfinden,
wie wir eine öffentliche
Politik entwickeln können,
die sicherstellt, dass
wir gleichberechtigt
und fair und gerecht sind.
- Es gibt Orte, die
sich bei der Erbringung
digitaler Dienstleistungen
hervortun, aber ich habe
noch keine Regierung gesehen, die dann die
Daten im Backend für
Kundeneinblicke, für prädiktive
Analysen, geospatiale Analysen
und wirkliche Leistungsoptimierung erntet.
- Nur weil Sie einen großen,
umfangreichen Datensatz haben,
heißt das nicht zwangsläufig,
dass er Ihnen in irgendeiner
Weise helfen kann, wenn Sie
keinen Wert oder keine Informationen
aus diesen Rohdaten erschließen können.
Die Art und Weise, wie ich
darüber nachdenke, wie die
Regierung eine Rolle
spielen kann, besteht darin,
sich wirklich auf
Informationen zu konzentrieren,
die für die Wähler, die
politischen Entscheidungsträger,
die Bürger, die Einwohner oder
die Besucher wertvoll sind,
und diese Informationen zu
nutzen, um alle auf der gleichen
Seite zu haben, wie Erfolg
aussieht und wie man beurteilen
kann, ob man die Kriterien, die
man festgelegt hat, erreicht
hat oder nicht, und dann
letztendlich daraus zu lernen
und zu iterieren.
- Ich denke, die Kunden haben Erwartungen,
die sich drastisch von dem unterscheiden,
was Regierungen heute an
Dienstleistungen anbieten.
Und wir sollten die Lücke schließen.
- Ich mache mir Sorgen, dass
wir in einem Abschwung noch
effizienter sein müssen in
der Art, wie wir dienen.
Mit der Ausweitung der digitalen Dienste
müssen wir darüber nachdenken,
wie wir altmodische Dienste
auf eine neue Art durchführen.
- Eine Sache, die wir innerhalb
einer Stadt tun, kann sich
auf den Verkehr auswirken,
was sich auf den
Wohnungsbau auswirken kann,
was sich auf die Migration
von Menschen auswirken kann.
Wir müssen alles innerhalb der Systeme und
innerhalb der größeren
Mechanismen betrachten und nicht
nur einzelne Entscheidungen.
Stellen Sie sicher, dass
- Sie die richtigen Business Cases und die
richtige Governance haben,
denn Sie können nicht
innovativ sein, wenn es
ein Jahr dauert, bis ein
Business Case für einen
neuen Service genehmigt wird.
- Eine Sache, auf die sich
die Regierung in erster Linie
konzentrieren muss, ist der
Versuch, die Gemeinschaft zu
verstehen - und zwar auf
der Mikroebene einer Stadt.
Und der Einsatz von Technologie
ist eine Möglichkeit, dies
zu tun, aber auch die
Fähigkeit, sich tief in
die Gemeinschaften einzubetten,
um die größten
Herausforderungen zu verstehen,
mit denen die Menschen in
jeder Szene konfrontiert sind,
und dann in der Lage zu sein,
diese Daten auf eine Weise
zu nutzen, die tatsächlich
Veränderungen bewirken kann.
- Diese nächste Generation
kümmert sich mehr
um Themen wie den Planeten, Fragen
zur Wohngleichheit als
frühere Generationen.
Ich denke, wir müssen
die Regierung für sie
attraktiv machen.